to see what you saw on the presidency do
you think we'd change our mind about how
our how our system works yes
in a lot of ways obviously the one way
that I'm particularly I'm particularly
concerned about is our view of how the
how the press does its job of covering
government and although I all the polls
show a great deal of skepticism about
that anyway I think this the disgust
assistant would be even more profound it
would be it would be more focused and I
think I think the the concerns would be
greater and there would be there would
be based on inaccurate and rather
distressing examples of times when the
press just doesn't do a very good job
Jody Powell is former press secretary to
President Jimmy Carter and his author of
this brand new book Jody Powell the
other side of the story published by
tomorrow and he'll be with us for the
next hour to take your calls and to talk
about what it's like to be press
secretary to the President and also to
be a columnist he's currently a
columnist for the Los Angeles Times
syndicate and it just so happens it on
Sunday yesterday the Los Angeles Times
at a page one story by David Shaw a very
long in-depth look at the power of the
pundit and they say here power of the
pundit is fading and they use you as an
example here in the story of a new
columnist and let me just go down here
and pick up a quote where it says Powell
doesn't have much power as a columnist
he doesn't even have much exposure now
they're not talking just about you they
happen to quote you in-depth here
they're talking about a lot of columnist
today do you think the columnist has
lost its power I think yeah it's
certainly compared to what it was a
number of years ago we have so many
other channels of communication and even
of commentary and opinion that the
column particularly the pure opinion
analysis column is is those sort of
shaky legs and the columns that do best
I think and I haven't read Shaw's piece
although I'll talk to him about in a
long time a good bit before we wrote it
tend to becomes that mix a good bit of
reporting in with the with the with the
opinion in the in the calm
Terry and I think that that is
definitely direction that it's been it's
headed how often do you write a column
for the Dallas Times Herald and then the
Los Angeles Times in do it twice a week
is it tough some well some days it's
tough some days some days it flows very
well it's about like any other other
sort of writing some some weeks you have
a tough time choosing amongst four or
five good topics some weeks it's hard to
convince you you convince yourself that
there are there are even two good topics
that week that are worth 700 700
wheelers the old there's the old joke
about about columnist what are you gonna
write this week I'm gonna write about
700 worried that's what I'm gonna cry
in this week's news week and this would
be no surprise to our viewers there's a
Nixon in primetime story and it talks
about the CBS 60 minutes and the
American parade tomorrow night and also
another 60 minutes show where they use
excerpts from an interview with Frank
Gannon who is a former Nixon aide
there's a lot of talking here about
rehabilitation and all that do you see a
time where President Carter would come
would like to come back and have more of
a say-so than he does now about his
presidency Oh Isis I suspect so and I
suspect he will as time goes on the one
thing you can be sure of about it about
history is that it is always in the
process of being of being reassessed and
of course President Carter's most
actively engaged now and putting
together a Public Policy Center in in
Atlanta in association with Emory
University down there and I think that
will be the the basis for his
involvement and I'll continue on a
continuing way in in public policy both
foreign and domestic a lot of people who
were around at your Nixon think that he
was done in by the press do you feel the
same way about Jimmy Carter oh I don't
think President Carter was done in by
the press and I certainly am not
attempting to claim that that that the
election of 1980 was lost because of
bad press coverage what I do claim is
even if the Carter Administration had
been eminently successful in every way
and an overwhelming reelected whelmingly
reelected in 1980 sooner or later I
would have written this book because I
saw enough instances there enough
occasions when the press misinformed the
public when it was done and and what
seemed to me to be an inexcusable way
everybody makes mistakes but some
mistakes are worse than others
I saw situations in which innocent
people were damaged
sometimes seriously and in almost in a
permanent fashion and those innocent
people still suffer but the people who
committed the wrong who were journalists
go unpunished and given the tremendous
power that that journalism has a media
has in this society for you for it to
exist essentially in a situation in
which that there is very little for a
journalist to fear if he or she makes a
serious mistake but does someone a
horrible injustice I think his is highly
dangerous Jody Powell is our guest and
our phone lines are open at two oh two
six two eight two five two five if you
live in the central and eastern time
zones 202 seven eight three two seven
two seven if you live in the mountain or
Pacific time zones remember our 30-day
policy hold off if you've talked to us
within the last month let's play a
little game all of a sudden you're an
advisor to the three Democratic
presidential candidates and you're
talking about the media and their
relationship to the median how they use
the media what would you say to mr.
Mondale tonight if he said give me some
advice well I think the coming thing in
political campaigns and in handling the
press in the White House is to severely
limit access and one of the things that
has been obvious over the past really I
suppose eight maybe ten years as that a
candidate who subjects himself like a
presidential candidate to frequent
contact with the press particularly the
general election campaign a candidate
that does a number of public events do
today is going to suffer and the best
approach is that really I suppose the
first one the first one to do it really
well was was was President Nixon and
that something since 68 but even better
in 72 but you give them you give them
one good carefully planned and staged
event per day and then you shut them
down and if you have if you have other
events keep them small keep them closed
that sort of thing and and you don't
stop you don't stop on getting into the
car to answer questions you don't stop
getting on and off the plane you give
them what you wanted to have and and be
done with it in that same sort of
approach I think unfortunately is it's
what any smart political strategist is
going to say is going to say to a
candidate and that's an unfortunate
thing for the public and then for the
democratic process and in this country
but to some extent I think I think
journalists have brought that on
themselves because they have rewarded
they have they reward politicians and
candidates not intentionally who conduct
themselves that way and by extension
they penalize a candidate or or a public
figure who tries to conduct himself in a
world but in candid manner would you
tell mr. Mondale anything specific
besides that oh I have I have a I
haven't kept track of because of running
around selling this book of the campaign
close enough to give a big specific
advice on the on the various problems or
opportunities check on the other two in
just a moment Novi Michigan good evening
you're on the air Novi go ahead please
[Music]
what right has the Democrats I see were
ranking the president over the calls
through the Red Sea ie mine harbors in
Central America well I
[Music]
president ex-president colors went to
the World Court and he spent two years
there when our people are prisoner and
the rand and it didn't do a damn bit
right never questioned sir you have a
question for mr. Powell directly well
I'd like to know what it what goodies
thinks it's gonna do I mean the World
Court when we went to World Court and
getting doing good all right sir thank
you well of course I don't think anybody
certainly not the president expected
that the that the suit in the world
court was going to do any direct good
with Iran it was a way of focusing world
and international opinion on the
Iranians which perhaps had some marginal
benefit but nobody expected that a
decision by the World Court was going to
get them to determine lose as for the
present situation Nicaragua it's really
exactly reversed not Nicaragua is going
knock Nicaragua is going to the World
Court to institute suit against us and
the administration has said well we want
to that we won't allow jurisdiction it
certainly makes us look bad and
internationally to do something like
that and I think the caller makes a good
point what does it matter why did I not
go up make our best case and if there if
the court decides against us then go
ahead and do what we and what we intend
to do rather than than just a 9
jurisdiction at the ounces this is the
book the other side of the story it's
Jody Powell's first book first book last
book well I don't know you have to
recover a little more time to recover
from the writing of the first one before
you can make a commitment about a second
how long it take you well it took about
three years but off and on if you're
doing your writing two columns a week
another and other other things you
really can't devote full time to book
writing Los Angeles go ahead please
you're on with Jody Powell Jimmy Carter
what extent you think that a presence
personality has with regard to the way
the press treats him my feeling is that
and it may not be an objective one that
President Carter was not highly regarded
personally by people in the media and
thus I think of many achievements for
disregarded while President Reagan is
well liked and I think he gets away with
quite a bit in terms of lack of policy
achievements and I would ask your
opinion on what's more important
personality or political achievement
well there's no doubt that personality
does play a role in fact it's one of the
things I that I dress in the book and
you know I don't want to be in the
position of demanding perfection from
from journalists but it is does go a bit
far when you hear them say over and over
being well gee whiz you know Reagan is
just kind of a likable guy that's why we
we weren't particularly tough on him or
to hear them say well you know there's
something about that guy corridor I
didn't like you know that this this is
not a this is not this is not some sort
of high school popularity contest we're
running here this is the government of
the United States and it doesn't strike
me that that the degree to which you're
willing to to pat Fannie's and and and
be amiable with reporters you know ought
to be a major factor it seems to me that
the journalists like everybody else
ought to do their job without without
the necessity for a great deal of
stroking unfortunately that is not
always the case
did you and President Carter ever talk
about how he was not liked by the press
to some extent yes but by the time there
wasn't a whole heck of lot you could do
about it by the by the particularly
toward the end of the administration and
the things that might one might have
done we're not the sort of things he was
inclined to indulge in in any case so we
didn't spend a whole lot of time talking
about something you couldn't do much
about Philadelphia good evening go ahead
please yes mr. lamb I would tell you how
much I appreciate c-span then you are
the top thank you it's nice of you to
say that and what I've been waiting for
someone with credibility to
come on that I could ask about how the
public has taken President Carter to
task
I feel it the personal in front of me
that's how much I liked him and I
thought it was so intelligent such a
refined person and I get hurt when I
hear them say how carefully was kidding
and no one has explained it to me why
they feel that way I have a hard time
understanding some of that myself and
I'm probably more biased about the
matter than then you are I haven't set
out in this book basically to defend the
court administration although I deal
with most of the incidents I deal with
although that all came from those came
from those years I think you had in
terms of the attitude of the press which
officer to some extent is is reflected
in the attitude of the public on a
variety of things that entered into it
one thing we've already dealt with it
was his disinclination to to try to
curry favor to stroke people whether
there were politicians or as staff
members or or or journalists I think I
think another thing that entered into it
there was not exactly anybody's fault
but there it was was it that President
Carter came to Washington lacking to an
extent that no other modern president
has lacked any established group of
committed knee-jerk supporters here in
in in in permanent Washington so what
that meant wasn't severy president
quickly develops a group of knee-jerk
opponents and any controversial matter
that the the argument tended to be on
the one side the people that were
absolutely convinced that the president
was wrong or willing to say so and the
other side the people who were willing
to say that maybe he was and maybe he
Wotton well that's that's not exactly a
that's not exactly the the basis for it
for a pleasant confrontation if you're
the president Chicago go ahead please
yes the reason I'm calling is because I
was first like to thank you for the
program you having I think it's the
first program that we have an alum has
been
my questions concerned of what option
can someone take if they feel that
someone in the media is being unfair in
the way they are reporting the news are
there any requests for the politicians
involved that that is the basic problem
and I hate to say this but as it
presently stands in most cases you do
not have much in the way of recourse you
can try and it's worth the effort to go
to the individual reporter involved or
failing if that fails to his or her
editors and bosses and present your case
in a in a reasonable factual way and
asked for for the record to be set
straight but I got to tell you that in
most cases you're not going to get any
satisfaction for because you know one of
the one of the most distressing things
about American journalism to me as an
almost adamant refusal to admit that a
mistake has been made much less an
attempt to do anything to repair the
damage that has been done look at and I
I don't want to I don't wanna beat oh
that's too much but consider the network
news broadcast before example but six
seven eight stories a night six seven
nights a week 52 weeks a year now just
what we all know about human nature and
the frailty of mortals would make it I
think fairly obvious that some of those
stories are wrong and some of them are
seriously wrong now try to remember the
last time you heard an American network
news anchor look into the camera and say
ladies and gentlemen ABC CBS CNN you
name it report in such-and-such last
night we were wrong the fact of the
matter is such and such and we apologize
you just don't hear that and you nor do
you see it frankly in the Washington
Post or the New York Times of the Lost
those times the Wall Street Journal a
most other or Newsweek or time at other
major major news organizations in this
country and that is that is that is to
me the fundamental problem in in
journalism that sort of defensive
reaction that if you criticize us then
if you object to this story then it's
just because you're self-serving you're
probably lying about it the general the
general generally what you will get is
so-and-so has raised objections about
this story we stand by our story
the editors Columbus Ohio you're on with
Jody Powell go ahead please thank you I
have a couple questions the first deals
with the way things have gone for the
Reagan administration as far as or as
compared to what might happen in the
Carter Administration with things say
the meze affair and misinformation
that's come out of the the Reagan
administration and why I haven't it
seems had it come out of the Carter
Administration the press would have
dealt much more harshly with mr. Carter
and they still do deal harshly with them
and the second is do you believe that
Ronald Reagan channels the news more so
than any president in the past in the
way that he keeps certain things away
from the press to take the last part of
your question first yes and I must
confess some admiration for the for the
effectiveness with which this
administration has handled their their
their press coverage and and part of it
is in doing a more effective job than we
were ever able to do and controlling the
flow of information from the inside the
government to the press particularly in
in situations that might prove to be
embarrassing the reasons they're more
successful probably I've got time to go
into all of them I think they went into
it knowing much more clearly what they
intended to do and with a with a with a
much much greater determination and to
do just just that sort of thing I happen
to think that the Democrats on the whole
tend to be more fractious and and and
talk more and maybe talk too much and
that history of cannibalism probably
goes back much further the Democratic
Party than it does in the Republican
Party that there is all that involved in
it and I think it has contributed into a
situation in which I would agree and I I
don't I don't
certainly not advised in the matter that
if if what if what we know already about
Edie's and some of it would appear to be
somewhat serious know that frankly does
not appear that serious to me but if it
were my old friend Hamilton Jordan I
think you would say a much a much
greater hoorah about it than we're
seeing right now well then we have West
Coast lines open at 202 seven eight
three to seven to seven if you dial now
we still have plenty of time to get your
question or comment to a Jody Powell
let's go to Palestine Texas good evening
I'd like to ask mister power question
and this is based on the fact that
having worked in all that I felt like
mr. Carter President Carter received an
unfair wrath and I haven't heard much
media attention to it well he was
president the price of oil per barrel
skyrocketed during his administration
and it's my opinion it had been almost
impossible for any president to a
relatively controlled inflation during
that time and my follow-up to that is
doesn't he think that if the price of
all today would have continued the same
spiraling rates that we would have the
same amount of inflation today roughly
speaking yes and it is it is true that
that was certainly the major problem
with the economy during those years but
as my as my former boss once said life
is unfair and when things go right a
president gets credit for them whether
you had anything to do with it or not
and when things go wrong the president
gets blamed no matter what whether there
was anything they could have done about
it or not
and certainly I think and this this sort
of goes back to one of the earlier
questions and when things go right for a
president things tend to go right and
and and the press tends to follow along
and and and and the sort of the wake of
public opinion and if President Reagan
for example were facing severe economic
problems whether they were of his making
or not he would be getting much tougher
treatment by the press I think if you
remember back to about a year ago this
time when the economy it was was sort of
at its depths and there were some
questions about when the recovery would
would would start I don't I don't have
any hard figures on the matter but I
think he my my perception at the time
was that he was also getting at that
time much tougher much more critical
press coverage than in any other time
and and much tougher than he's getting
now in your book Jodie pal back in the
back guy when one lines stuck out in the
main it is probably not a good idea to
develop close friendships with reporters
who are covering the White House you're
now on the other side of the fence and
you're out working for ABC and doing
your own column and things like that you
still believe that that that's a that's
a problem it's a debatable point yes I
believe it there there are those who
have served in the same job that I
served in or in other public information
spokesmen girls and government who say
no I don't think that's true the
reasoning behind that the reason I said
that was that the the relationship
between a press secretary and a reporter
is as a tense enough bit of business
under the best of circumstances
sooner or later one of the other is
going to have to do something in the
course of his job or her job that's
going to make the other's life quite
difficult that's bad enough anyway if if
that sort of problem is exacerbated by
the fact by a personal relationship that
it that has that has been violated if
your reaction is not how could that
rascal do this to me but how could that
rascal who said in my home bounce my
children on his knee drank my good
liquor you know how could so how could
he do this to me I think it makes those
inevitable evitable difficult moments
even more difficulty and you just sort
of asking for additional trouble that
you don't need send come any good
evening
I didn't get into that in a great deal
of detail suffice it to say though that
by the general election in nineteen by
the fall of 1980 and it really really
beginning several months before then and
the relationships between the president
and the White House press corps were
were absolutely terrible and there was a
general feeling and I and I this is not
just my view now this is based on what
reporters said some of them at the time
and and and certainly many more of them
since then they had developed this idea
that the president was was was
manipulative that that he couldn't be
trusted in these sorts of things that
his actions tended to be self-serving
which in my point of view was quite the
opposite from it from the truth but
nevertheless the press corps as a group
had had come to to this sort of view so
it was very hard for him under those
circumstances to get them to pay much
attention to claims of you know that
this is this is an accomplishment this
is worth noting and so forth beyond that
and and to take it quite out of those
area of a press relations the fact was
that the economy was in such bad shape
then that and and that issue more than
anything else affects Americans during
election that it was that it was very
hard for a president even to get the
attention of the American people and say
yes the economy's in bad shape now but
it will get better
and don't forget there was Camp David
and there was this and there was that
that in the other one economy goes sour
it's tough and even even with the best
of press relations and even if the press
were perfect in the way it did its job
president have a tough time getting
reelected with the economy and his
shape as it was in the fall of 80 about
the halfway point our guest is Jody
Powell and this is his first book this
is all about the years in the Carter
White House the other side of the story
and by the way for those of you who
can't get through tonight this gentleman
will be up quite late he'll be on the
Larry King show and you can get a chance
to get to him then after an hour
interview probably about one o'clock so
if you can't get through in here and
you're gonna be up call the Larry King
show on your mutual outlet Granville
Ohio go ahead please yes I would like to
say that I I think that the Democratic
presidential candidates are making a big
mistake in backing away from Carter
because the piece the piece that Carter
negotiated between Israel and Egypt at
Camp David has lasted a long time for
five years and there were no American
dead and the piece that Reagan provided
in Lebanon fell apart almost immediately
and I don't think that the Democratic
presidential candidates have anything to
apologize for it upsets me that they
that they back away from Carter's
presidency also this our there's
something else I'd like to say is that
there's so many people most of most of
them probably Republican say I'm not I'm
not in agreement with Reagan on ER a I
don't agree with him on arms control I
don't agree with them on El Salvador but
you asked them who they're going to vote
for and they'll say Reagan they'll say
well Reagan I guess so there's something
going on here that I wish there Jodie
could explain I don't know if I get it I
don't know if I can explain it or not I
think what you say there is one of the
reasons that I'm not one of those who
believes that the president is is
invulnerable in the in the fall but what
you say there is also one of the reasons
that I I do happen to think that at this
point he has to be considered a has to
be considered a strong favorite he is a
likable person both privately I might
say and in his public persona he has
been quite successful as as even his his
most ardent supporters will admit
and sort of being there when the
building collapses but but walking away
with what not even any plaster dust in
his in his hair whether that sort of
thing catches up with him between now
and in the in the fall in the fall
I don't know big controversy or at least
a press controversy over louis
farrakhan's comments about milton
Coleman and the Jesse Jackson campaign
not quite the question on that specific
issue but are we really as citizens
getting the real picture is off the
record used for the convenience of the
politicians and the media and when you
were in the White House did you in the
media have a lot of exchange off the
record that we never heard about not off
the record so much off the records the
sort of term that's hardly ever hardly
ever used and most most journalists just
don't want to get involved in an
off-the-record discussion not about any
sort of serious matters now you do have
situations as which by their very nature
the parties generally assume or off the
record there are there are social
situations in which in neither the
journal that the journalists don't want
to be working the the press secretary of
the White House staffers or whatever
don't one have to be watching every word
that they say and so you just sort of
naturally assume look you know this is
this is not the basis or story but the
fundamental rule in dealing with
reporters I think is is you've got to be
careful not to tempt them beyond what
they can bear no matter what the ground
rules are and they're usually what
what's known as as on background which
means that if I tell you something on
background you could you could report it
and say and attribute it if it were four
years ago to a White House aide or a
senior White House official or so forth
or a deep background which means that if
I told you something on deep background
you could use it but you couldn't
attribute it to anybody you would have
to say it as though it were of your own
own personal knowledge in those areas
they're fine the ground rules are
usually observed but again you tempt you
tempt somebody beyond what they're what
they're likely to bear and even if they
observe the ground rules and they don't
quote you by name
the word will get around and and your
name will pop up attached to that quote
in somebody else's a story in the damage
has been done I don't know how much
influence does your wife have on you
he's not with us he's no wives all right
you know I that was one of the
interesting aspects of that
administration that I really I never had
much of a handle on was was folks
getting so upset at the idea that the
president of the United States who also
happened to be a husband talked about
what he was doing on his job with his
wife and he considered to be an
intelligent woman although not by no
means an expert on foreign affairs just
as most most advisors to a president or
not experts in a particular area of
government but someone that he liked to
talk to that he that he liked to hash
things over with whose general views and
an insight and an intellect he he was he
respected and it was put to what
particularly was hard to me to
understand that some of those that
seemed to get the most exercise about
the idea that the president's wife was
playing some improper world role because
she talked to her husband were those who
and in a more general sense would be the
first the first to jump to the defense
off the the importance of women and the
right of women and of an N of wives to
be something other than and certainly
the first ladies to do something other
than then then then buy clothes and hold
and hold tea parties in the in the in
the mansion when you start playing this
book then your tomorrow company suggests
to you that you had to write certain
things in order
it's sellable not really no as a matter
of fact what I set out to do in the
proposal I submitted to them and other
publishers it was basically a question
of sort of who bid for the who bid on
based on the proposal was somewhat
different from this and I decided after
about a year and a half of working on
the original proposal that that was not
that wasn't working and I've ended up
with a book that may raise more hackles
mayor lose a friend to do although I
doubt it but which says much more
clearly and forthrightly and I believe
honestly you know what I honestly feel
and what I would like to say to the
American people about the way the
present offer is you have to deal today
with your colleagues in the media at ABC
and your columnist world and all that do
are the media just like politicians
where you fight it out in the daytime
and then you go home at night and your
friends there there is there is there is
some of that and frankly I think on the
whole defending reporters here more
often than I intended to but on the
whole and one of the points I make I
make there is that is that reporters
probably are better than most
politicians about that and comparing my
job in dealing with the press with Frank
Moyes job dealing with it with the
Congress and I felt like I could get
away with a lot more in terms of telling
reporters exactly what I thought of a
story and sometimes in colorful and
heated language and and and get away
with it and have it it said it's over
let's go on then anybody any any White
House to ever would dare do with a with
a member of Congress or a United States
Senator Fairfield California in the San
Francisco Bay Area good evening person
I'm getting is that blacks will support
white candidates but whites don't
support black candidates and I really
think the reason Jesse is running it's
to bring this out that for so long
rights that okay we will use
them to better our people because we're
always accused of being on welfare even
though there are more white people on
welfare than black people so Jesse's
saying if I have a good program both
listen to it and book for me but I
notice wait don't even look caller do
you think the media has been fair to
Jesse Jackson well I don't blame the
media I think the media takes a bad rap
to start with I listen to the grenada
thing and I'm black you know and I
didn't think we should go into Grenada I
think the people of Grenada and I think
most blacks feel this way alright sir
thanks for the call mr. Powell do you
think that blacks will vote for whites
but White's won't vote for blacks
well certainly that is a pattern and
it's an unfortunate one is it is not
altogether true by any means there have
been more than one or two occasions in
which which blacks have been elected
from majority white constituencies one
that has to be quite familiar with was
Andrew Young and was first elected from
it to Congress and then relit from it
from a district that was not just
slightly white in his majority but but
fairly predominantly why didn't in its
majority uuuugh you can point to others
too but on the whole there is certainly
a much greater reluctance on the part of
whites to vote for black candidates than
there is on the part of blacks to vote
for vote for white candidates and I
would disagree a little bit with what it
seems to me maybe ought to be the lesson
of of the Jackson of the Jackson
campaign he clearly years despite all
that having an impact and he is by I
think showing people all over the
country but and of all sorts of
particularly black people that
registering to vote and getting out to
vote even though and as in his case
might be backing a candidate who is not
likely to win can't have an impact on
the political process and he will be in
a position going into the convention and
then and in the fall you know to get
people to make people listen to what
he's what he's got to say and I would
disagree with it with it with it with
the idea that that why people don't
listen to what Jackson has to say I
think a lot of white people do and I
don't mean just just just reporters and
columnist and journalists I think the
fact that he is an articulate spokesman
for ideas that aren't just black ideas
but that were late to the problems of
people that haven't had a decent shake
whatever their whatever their the race I
think that comes that comes to very
strongly excuse me Chilton ham
Pennsylvania good evening I haven't had
a chance to to read the mayor's book he
and I have traded some some insults at
long range over I guess basically what I
said about him and in my book but I'll
be glad to try to deal with your
question anyway
chapter of the book in which he
discusses the presidential campaign in
1980 he claims that he was able to
extract certain concessions from from
President Carter so that he would
continue to support President Carter and
indeed even went down to Miami Beach to
campaign in the last week of the
election right before the election these
were questions concerning support for
Israel and some some questions regarding
Medicaid or Medicare which but in any
case you were quite involved at that
time was dealing with with the mayor
indicated in the book he also described
the President Carter I believe is having
the mean streak of not being a very nice
person to deal with but that he
basically had to go along with him in
the end because the President Carter had
come through with making certain
concessions with regard to Israel by the
way I agree that mayor cut should have
done those things because that's an
effect lobbying for a relatively good
purpose and the president quarters
position on Israel basically
flip-flopped day after the Camp David
affair and there were many people in
this country who were very unhappy with
the way the Carter Administration
handled the questions involving Israel
and indeed voted for President Reagan
for that particular reason but as far as
the as far as the book I wonder what
your comment well yeah let me say up
front that I'm not a great fan of mayor
kite and if you get a chance to read
what I have to say about in my book
it'll be a very clear he reminds me more
than anybody outs of an old adversary
from Georgia named Lester Maddox who had
some of the mayor's unless endearing
characteristics including his his
inclination to lay off all his problems
on somebody else never to accept
responsibility for any of his own
mistakes and even to the sort of
practiced buffoonery and outrages
comment and and I was saying and
slightly more serious vain to the to the
the the the appeal and the exacerbation
to to ethnic and racial difficulties as
far as extracting concessions on Israel
you know I don't have a no idea what the
mayor is talking about I'm sure that's
not true it is certainly true that over
the course of three four years you know
the President did President Carter did
do a great deal for a New York City at
considerable political cost to himself
the idea of quote bailing out New York
clothes code as it was as it was known
in much of the country at the time
was not politically popular but the
president stood by it and fought it and
fought it through you know the amount of
political risks were support he received
in from from Ed Koch in return was was
slim to none the one concession that I
do remember quite specifically and
indeed indeed deal with in the book is
that that the President did agree to
hold and the Democratic convention in
New York yes mayor Koch wanted and
Governor Kerry wanted in return for a
commitment from both of those two
fellows that they would support his Reid
nomination as it turned out the
conviction was held in was held in New
York that's the only part of that bill
that ever got that ever got implemented
though in case you doubt mr. Powell's
feelings about mayor Koch let me read
you a paragraph here in his book under
the Fear and Loathing in New York
chapter there was also the matter of
then Governor Hugh Carey and New York
City Mayor Ed Koch no more slippery pair
of political ingrates that ever sidled
into the oval office hat in one hand
Shiv in the other to me they epitomize
what was wrong with American politics
and the Democratic Party
they were self-serving unscrupulous and
congenitally unable to accept the
responsibility for their own problems
anything else strongly you had to say
about that generally sums it up I guess
Miami Beach Florida good evening thank
you sir would you please turn down here
television set so you don't get that
feedback get the delay on the satellite
you get the feedback and it kind of
throws you off when you're trying to ask
a question go ahead Miami Beach
[Music]
[Music]
you know the capital and it's very true
Amsterdam is the capital of heart and
our embassy is in the hague we just
totally different and so you know the
candidates I don't believe in them
because they don't know about that
and it's haven't well I happen to think
in this case the what that what the
gentleman says it's true and to me the
real the real problem and that is that
it's that it is a rather cynical bid for
a political support on the part of these
Democratic candidates and it's a
terrible idea
it does absolutely nothing for the
interest of this country and the short
term or the long term if Frank frankly
does very little for the even the
interest of Israel and it's one of the
unfortunate aspects of about American
foreign policy as it gets a it gets
sometimes jerked around and we get
distracted from what our real interest
are in election years candidates try to
pander to this or that particular
interest in our society you write two
columns a week for the Los Angeles Times
syndicate do you have an approach to
column writing that you feel is
different from the others well I hope
the fact that I that I spent some time
on the other side of the fence both in
the political system and in in
government gives me a bit of insight
that maybe some people who haven't had
that experience they don't have an and
it's certainly the fact that a lot of
people that I knew in those days as
colleagues you know now function
occasionally as sources as helpful to do
you write more about people or about
policies it varies and and I probably
more about policies because I think
there's a too great of a of a tendency
in some cases to over personalized
what's going on in the end of political
process - to try to identify a
particular policy or a particular idea
with an individual and if this if you
like the policy then the individuals are
fine fine gentlemen in a statesman if
you don't like the policy they need the
nation and he must be a rascal in fact
my experience has been in some of the
more decent and honorable people I know
have put forward some very bad policies
and some in some of some of the Prime
Rascals of the nation that have on
occasion come forward with some some
very good ideas I think I think it never
got quite as high but I think the rise
was about as dramatic what we've had is
a period of process of cycle in which
inflation rate would go up with our
recession it would come down but it
generally never went down quite as low
as it was before and so when it started
up again
it went up from a from a from a higher
base I don't think you're in the Nixon
years he got he got quite the shot the
inflation shot from the oil price rise
in terms of its ultimate impact as
as the President Carter did during his
hit his administration but the effect
was roughly the same looks call the
other side of the story here's the cover
written by Jody Powell just on your in
your bookstores in the last couple weeks
how's it selling Tara Lee didn't have
any any hard figures on the thing
because it's it's it's really only been
out for about about a week or so but
from the early indications very well so
I'm keeping my my fingers when you write
a book like this do you count on it to
help make your living for you is this
done out of it you really don't I mean I
think you you know I think most writers
you write the book by the time it's
finished you spent the advance and if it
earns back more than the advance and
somewhere down the road you get a few
dollars in Royal did you consider that
to be to be found money I've got a
daughter put through college but I'm not
I haven't really budgeted proceeds from
the book to pay the tuition you are
still living here in Washington I am
still living by the way our coverage of
the Pennsylvania primary continues later
tonight however our troops are finished
up there and we're filling up the
transportable uplink and bring her back
to Washington everybody's looking
forward to the next couple of weeks as a
respite from the campaign there won't be
any other big elections I don't want to
slight anybody out there but the big
primaries are then put off until May 5th
in Texas and I think their caucus is
actually in Texas and on May 8th Ohio
Indiana and Maryland so everybody's
looking forward to a breather do you
think we need it I suspect we probably
do and it's gonna be it's gonna be an
interesting new thing in the nominating
process to have this two week or so
hiatus really then followed by another
until you get to the to the first the
first week in June and I'm not quite
sure what effect that's going to have on
on the on the process as someone at that
point is an is in serious shape it might
give them a chance to sort of pull
things together get things back on get
things back on the track again on the
other hand and it might also provide the
time for a front runner to even build up
an even greater head of steam reminder
West Coast callers that that number is
reserved for 202 7 8 3 to 7 to 7 if
you're calling from the east on that
number we won't take the call or put you
on the air you got a stem line with
the East Coast number for the central
and eastern time zones which is two oh
two six two eight two five two five want
to thank the Philadelphia Inquirer for
hosting us in Philadelphia and as usual
they were good hosts we first did our
day in the life series of a newspaper
four years ago right now at the
Philadelphia Inquirer back in April of
1980 I'm gonna go back to the phones
waiting on another call for Jody Powell
have a little trouble getting one on the
line here well I think it is quite
possible yes that if he had done sort of
what President Nixon did and instituted
wage and price controls all there was a
little bit more difficult to do for
reasons that are probably too
complicated to go into but if he had
done that it probably would have helped
somewhat politically it would look like
he was doing something dramatic and and
indecisive and it would have in the
short term probably held down and and
and and brought down the inflation rate
the problem however is that in the long
term that would have better been a very
bad idea and that's one of the things we
found out died when President Nixon did
is that even even
though you can you can with wage and
price controls put a lid on even reduce
inflation in the short term that when
you take them off you pay the price
double for what you gained and that's
why he refused to do it said he was
against it from from day one and never
came close to changing his mind tomorrow
morning 9 o'clock Ted Lyons with
Terrence Smith of the New York Times
good old New London Connecticut good
evening good evening mr. Powell a couple
of questions if I man and get his
answers in between the questions sure
this first of all I'd like to ask mr.
Collard if you think the media served
any purpose by televising the Iranian
protests and turan of the anti-american
sentiments over there during the days of
the hostage crisis I know if it served a
useful purpose and it probably it is it
is not what not just probably it
certainly is true in my judgment that to
a degree the American press was used by
the Iranians who are really quite good
at the surprisingly good at the the
public relations game and frankly I
think a large number of American
journalists look on looking back on it
and they all say the same things and
have said the same things themselves
that those demonstrations that could be
produced sort of on demand any time a
television camera showed up made a nice
backdrop and it was a little more
exciting than having a correspondent
standing there against a blank wall but
they didn't remain didn't mean a great
deal except as a testimony to the
organizing ability of the Iranian
advancement on the whole though I
thought would would and as well and
there were a couple of other cases one
in which I forget which network actually
paid the Iranian terrorists money for
them to deliver on camera to interviews
of American hostages who frankly had no
alternative but to do
those interviews and in which the
network had no idea what sort of
pressure they might have might have been
under what the background of it was and
I thought that was I thought that was
one of the the tawdry or exhibitions in
journalism and I saw in the
administration story kids being killed
napalm being dropped on kids and you
know without any kind of response from
the military finding out that's a tough
that's a very very tough issue and it's
one that's not going to go away from us
anytime soon at one level it engages
sort of what happens to journalism when
it when it in wartime tries to present
so the view of the of the other side
what happens to journalism indeed when
it puts itself in the hands of a an
entity and whether it's a guerrilla
movement or a foreign government that
basically makes no pretense of having
any respect for that for the sort of
rules that we generally honor in terms
of the press and in this course you know
what is to what extent do they allow
themselves to be used an even larger
question is you can say on the one hand
you know if we're gonna fight war as we
ought to be willing here on the home
front
to see what war is really like and we
ought to understand that it's that it's
not much glory and it is a heck of a lot
of pain and suffering and death on on
both sides the flip side of that is
whether even if that's what it ought to
be whether or not a democracy
can fight a war even if no matter even
if it is the most just war that one can
imagine over the long haul faced with
that sort of coverage every year every
evening on television I don't know the
answer either one of those crazy I
remember growing up anyone treating
White's like with white sheets here call
her where are you from originally thank
you very much we have about 30 seconds
Joelle well there have been some
occasions which I think the press has
been unfair to Jesse Jackson as as the
hard as de Mondale I really don't think
there's a campaign there though and
although yes there is some biased
against blacks in amongst some in
journalism just as I thought and I think
corrected there was some biased against
others it is not that is not a basic and
widespread problem in in the press the
problems the problems are a good bit
more complicated than man Jody Powell
the other side of the story is the name
of the book title of the book published
by tomorrow in the bookstores right now
our guest for the last hour and we want
to thank him very much for coming and
joining us and look forward to having
returned sometime when you another
controversial issue pop up maybe not a
book that time but he's always welcome
in our mark
I'll have a good day
[Music]